This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。人类出品，必属精品。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）为你带来的《以硬核方式学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全地进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，请收听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.|||在 AHA 电台应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《以硬核方式学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.|||我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《困于爱网》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《困于爱网》播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he did.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he did.|||我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何平台上的 T-W-O-百分之二。当一群女性发现她们约会的都是同一个声名狼藉的惯犯时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的。
deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. Before we get into today's episode, I have a really special announcement. And if you're listening to the episode in the week that it is coming out, you might be some of the first people to know. I wrote a book and come 2025, it will be yours. It is called Person in Progress. And much like this podcast, it's a psychological roadmap basically to your 20s with even more studies,
deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. Before we get into today's episode, I have a really special announcement. And if you're listening to the episode in the week that it is coming out, you might be some of the first people to know. I wrote a book and come 2025, it will be yours. It is called Person in Progress. And much like this podcast, it's a psychological roadmap basically to your 20s with even more studies,|||应得的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，在 Iheart radio 应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析你的二十岁心理学。在进入今天的节目之前，我有一个非常特别的宣布。如果你在节目刚发布的这一周收听，你可能是第一批知道的人之一。我写了一本书，到 2025 年，它将属于你们。它叫《成长中的人》（Person in Progress）。就像这个播客一样，它基本上是你二十岁人生的一份心理路线图，其中包含更多的研究、
even more guided exercises, even more personal stories. And it is for you guys to have and to hold. I cannot even believe that those words are coming out of my mouth. I wrote a book. Before I tell you any more details, I want to just firstly say thank you. And to just express my very deep gratitude for every single listener of the podcast, there is not a moment that I don't pinch myself and feel so grateful to have you all because it would have never been possible without your continued support.
even more guided exercises, even more personal stories. And it is for you guys to have and to hold. I cannot even believe that those words are coming out of my mouth. I wrote a book. Before I tell you any more details, I want to just firstly say thank you. And to just express my very deep gratitude for every single listener of the podcast, there is not a moment that I don't pinch myself and feel so grateful to have you all because it would have never been possible without your continued support.|||更多的引导练习、更多的个人故事。这是专属于你们、供你们拥有和珍藏的。我甚至不敢相信这些话是从我嘴里说出来的。我写了一本书。在我告诉你更多细节之前，我想首先说一声谢谢。并对播客的每一位听众表达我深深的感激之情，没有哪一个时刻我不需要掐自己一下来确认这不是梦，能拥有你们大家我感到无比感激，因为如果没有你们的持续支持，这一切都绝无可能。
Without all of you who tune in week after week, you know, I may have written the book, but you are the reason I had the opportunity. So before I say anything else, I just want to say thank you and that I think you'll love this book as much, if not more, than the podcast and the episodes that I put out each week. So person in progress, let me tell you a little bit more about it. I've been in the process of writing this book for the last two years. I've given some hints here and there that it would be coming. So it's great to like finally have it out in the open. Person in Progress is made up of four sections. They are welcome to your
Without all of you who tune in week after week, you know, I may have written the book, but you are the reason I had the opportunity. So before I say anything else, I just want to say thank you and that I think you'll love this book as much, if not more, than the podcast and the episodes that I put out each week. So person in progress, let me tell you a little bit more about it. I've been in the process of writing this book for the last two years. I've given some hints here and there that it would be coming. So it's great to like finally have it out in the open. Person in Progress is made up of four sections. They are welcome to your|||如果没有你们每周都来收听，你知道的，也许是我写了这本书，但你们才是我拥有这个机会的原因。所以在说其他任何事情之前，我只想说谢谢，并且我认为你们会像喜欢我每周发布的播客和节目一样，甚至更喜欢这本书。所以关于《成长中的人》，让我多告诉你一点。在过去的两年里，我一直在写这本书。我在这里和那里透露过它即将问世的线索。所以很高兴终于能把它公之于众了。《成长中的人》由四个部分组成。它们是：欢迎来到你的
quarter life crisis, love on the brain, work in progress and everybody is healing from something. It covers so many of the complicated experiences of your 20s. It's over 300 pages. We talk about how to figure out exactly what you should be doing in your life, exactly who your authentic self is, how to make friends as an adult, how to stop repeating history in relationships, how to use psychology to fall in love, to heal guilt, shame, embarrassment, loneliness and so much more. I could literally keep going. It is also available for pre-order right now, like at this very moment. It's just such a pinch-by moment to like even be saying that.
quarter life crisis, love on the brain, work in progress and everybody is healing from something. It covers so many of the complicated experiences of your 20s. It's over 300 pages. We talk about how to figure out exactly what you should be doing in your life, exactly who your authentic self is, how to make friends as an adult, how to stop repeating history in relationships, how to use psychology to fall in love, to heal guilt, shame, embarrassment, loneliness and so much more. I could literally keep going. It is also available for pre-order right now, like at this very moment. It's just such a pinch-by moment to like even be saying that.|||四分之一人生危机、大脑中的爱、进行中的工作以及每个人都在疗愈某种伤痛。它涵盖了你二十岁时许多复杂的经历。它有300多页。我们讨论了如何弄清楚你到底应该在生活中做什么，你真实的自我究竟是谁，如何在成年后交朋友，如何在亲密关系中停止重蹈覆辙，如何利用心理学坠入爱河，如何疗愈内疚、羞耻、尴尬、孤独等等。我真的可以一直说下去。它现在就可以预订了，就在此时此刻。甚至连说出这句话都让我觉得像在做梦一样。
But if you do feel cool to do so, grab a pre-order copy now so that you get the book the day it comes out. Another benefit, it really helps get the book into local bookstores and into local shops, local bookshops, because pre-order numbers help people determine the quantities that they're going to order come release. So if you are excited to get your hands on it, as am I, please consider pre-ordering through the link in the description. Again, thank you, thank you, thank you for giving me this opportunity and for giving me this platform. There will be so many more details to come in the following months. And if you want to see the cover, head to my Instagram and you can see so many more details and exactly what is going to be in your hands come 2025.
But if you do feel cool to do so, grab a pre-order copy now so that you get the book the day it comes out. Another benefit, it really helps get the book into local bookstores and into local shops, local bookshops, because pre-order numbers help people determine the quantities that they're going to order come release. So if you are excited to get your hands on it, as am I, please consider pre-ordering through the link in the description. Again, thank you, thank you, thank you for giving me this opportunity and for giving me this platform. There will be so many more details to come in the following months. And if you want to see the cover, head to my Instagram and you can see so many more details and exactly what is going to be in your hands come 2025.|||但是，如果你觉得这样做很酷，现在就去下一本预订副本吧，这样书一出版你就能拿到手。另一个好处是，这确实有助于将这本书推广到当地的书店和店铺，即本地书店，因为预订量有助于人们在发行时决定订购的数量。所以，如果你像我一样渴望拿到这本书，请考虑通过描述中的链接进行预订。再次感谢，感谢，感谢你们给我这个机会，给我这个平台。在接下来的几个月里，还会有更多的细节公布。如果你想看封面，请前往我的 Instagram，你可以看到更多的细节，以及到 2025 年时究竟会有什么呈现在你手中。
Without further ado, let's get into the episode. Today, we are going to be talking about how to create a soft life in your 20s. And what I mean by that is how do we create a life of simple pleasures, of joy, one that is gentle, happy, successful, without feeling heavy and frustrating as everything so often feels these days. It is a daily reality for a lot of us in this decade. We are so focused on progress and success. It's been drilled into our brains. We are focused on not falling behind on this like predetermined race course that we all are traveling on. And it means that our lives, firstly, no longer seem like ours. And at times they don't even feel enjoyable. All of our
Without further ado, let's get into the episode. Today, we are going to be talking about how to create a soft life in your 20s. And what I mean by that is how do we create a life of simple pleasures, of joy, one that is gentle, happy, successful, without feeling heavy and frustrating as everything so often feels these days. It is a daily reality for a lot of us in this decade. We are so focused on progress and success. It's been drilled into our brains. We are focused on not falling behind on this like predetermined race course that we all are traveling on. And it means that our lives, firstly, no longer seem like ours. And at times they don't even feel enjoyable. All of our|||闲话少说，让我们进入本期节目。今天，我们要讨论的是如何在二十岁时创造一种“松弛的生活”（soft life）。我的意思是，我们如何创造一种充满简单快乐、喜悦的生活，一种温和、快乐、成功的生活，而不会像如今的许多事情那样常常感到沉重和沮丧。这是这十年里我们许多人每天都要面对的现实。我们太专注于进步和成功了。这已经深深烙印在我们的脑海里。我们全神贯注于不要在这个我们都在奔跑的预定赛道上落后。这意味着我们的生活，首先，似乎不再是我们自己的了。有时它们甚至让人觉得毫无乐趣。我们所有的
attention and our energy is like focused on work. It's focused on school. It's focused on achievement. And it's dictated by like this urgency culture to be doing it all and to have it all together right now. to be rushing from one milestone to the next, from one place to the next, I think it's time that we slow down. It's my belief that when we really buy into this during our 20s, this like overarching perspective and attitude towards life, and we don't have the occasional reminder that life is short and we actually need to enjoy it. We end up being overwhelmed by unnecessary stress and we prioritize productivity rather than being kind to ourselves, being gentle to ourselves, experiencing the world, shaking off that philosophy as well, it becomes harder the older we get.
attention and our energy is like focused on work. It's focused on school. It's focused on achievement. And it's dictated by like this urgency culture to be doing it all and to have it all together right now. to be rushing from one milestone to the next, from one place to the next, I think it's time that we slow down. It's my belief that when we really buy into this during our 20s, this like overarching perspective and attitude towards life, and we don't have the occasional reminder that life is short and we actually need to enjoy it. We end up being overwhelmed by unnecessary stress and we prioritize productivity rather than being kind to ourselves, being gentle to ourselves, experiencing the world, shaking off that philosophy as well, it becomes harder the older we get.|||注意力和精力都集中在工作上。集中在学校上。集中在成就上。并且它被这种紧迫感文化所支配，要求我们现在就做完所有事情并把一切都掌控好。从一个里程碑冲向另一个里程碑，从一个地方冲向另一个地方，我认为是时候放慢脚步了。我相信，当我们在二十多岁时真正接受这一点，即这种包罗万象的人生观和态度，而我们又没有偶尔得到提醒：生命短暂，我们实际上需要享受生活。我们最终会被不必要的压力压垮，我们会把生产力放在首位，而不是善待自己、温柔对待自己、体验世界。要摆脱这种哲学，随着年龄的增长，也会变得越来越困难。
So it's a very formative period where we can rewrite the script that we have been taught on how to enjoy our lives. That is what we want. We do not want to be operating at this really high stress frequency for, you know, the next 30, 40 years are never slowing down. I think it also comes down to this very important thing to remember, which is that in a culture of hustling and in the culture of success, you don't need to burn out to prove that you deserve good things. You don't need to deny yourself simple pleasures to prove you're a good person. We want to take a more, I would say positive psychology approach. We want to take our mental health and our emotional health seriously by deliberately choosing and
So it's a very formative period where we can rewrite the script that we have been taught on how to enjoy our lives. That is what we want. We do not want to be operating at this really high stress frequency for, you know, the next 30, 40 years are never slowing down. I think it also comes down to this very important thing to remember, which is that in a culture of hustling and in the culture of success, you don't need to burn out to prove that you deserve good things. You don't need to deny yourself simple pleasures to prove you're a good person. We want to take a more, I would say positive psychology approach. We want to take our mental health and our emotional health seriously by deliberately choosing and|||所以这是一个非常具有塑造性的时期，我们可以重写被教导的关于如何享受生活的剧本。这正是我们想要的。我们不想在接下来的 30、40 年里以这种极高压的频率运作，却从不放慢脚步。我认为这归结为一个非常重要的事情要记住，那就是在内卷文化和成功文化中，你不需要精疲力竭来证明你值得拥有美好的事物。你不需要剥夺自己的简单快乐来证明你是个好人。我们想要采取一种，可以说更偏向积极心理学的态度。我们要通过刻意选择和
pursuing a soft life. The soft life is about slowing down. It's about adopting a lifestyle of enjoyment, comfort, ease, simple pleasure. And it came from the Nigerian wellness community and from black female creators who were sharing this new approach in the last two to three years that really combines agency, ambition, freedom without the need to sacrifice. what you enjoy and to always put others above you, put yourself under this intense stress, you go easier on yourself, you appreciate the details of life rather than rushing through them. If you want to read about the exact history of this term, there is an amazing article by Anscape, which is like an online journal titled The Soft Life Isn't as Easy as It Looks Online.
pursuing a soft life. The soft life is about slowing down. It's about adopting a lifestyle of enjoyment, comfort, ease, simple pleasure. And it came from the Nigerian wellness community and from black female creators who were sharing this new approach in the last two to three years that really combines agency, ambition, freedom without the need to sacrifice. what you enjoy and to always put others above you, put yourself under this intense stress, you go easier on yourself, you appreciate the details of life rather than rushing through them. If you want to read about the exact history of this term, there is an amazing article by Anscape, which is like an online journal titled The Soft Life Isn't as Easy as It Looks Online.|||追求松弛的生活，来认真对待我们的心理健康和情绪健康。“松弛的生活”意味着放慢脚步。它意味着采纳一种享受、舒适、轻松、简单快乐的生活方式。它源自尼日利亚的健康社群以及黑人女性创作者，她们在过去的两三年里分享了这种新方法，它真正结合了自主性、雄心、自由，而无需牺牲你所享受的东西，也无需总是把别人放在自己之上、把自己置于这种巨大的压力之下。你对自己的要求会更轻松一些，你会去欣赏生活的细节，而不是匆忙掠过它们。如果你想了解这个词的确切历史，Anscape（一个类似在线期刊的网站）有一篇精彩的文章，题为《松弛的生活并不像网上看起来那么容易》。
And they interview some of the originators of this term. It's incredibly fascinating for, you know, where their desire to embrace the soft life and promote the soft life really came from. I like to think of it as well as really living similarly to how our ancestors would have lived long ago. They would have woken with the sun. They would have felt their feet on the earth. They would have watched the trees move, watched the sunset, enjoyed like the sweetness of the berries really savored it. They would have done just what they needed to. survive and then rest easy at night with their clan. They didn't have to do lists. They didn't have
And they interview some of the originators of this term. It's incredibly fascinating for, you6 know, where their desire to embrace the soft life and promote the soft life really came from. I like to think of it as well as really living similarly to how our ancestors would have lived long ago. They would have woken with the sun. They would have felt their feet on the earth. They would have watched the trees move, watched the sunset, enjoyed like the sweetness of the berries really savored it. They would have done just what they needed to. survive and then rest easy at night with their clan. They didn't have to do lists. They didn't have|||他们采访了这个词的一些创始人。你知道的，他们想要拥抱松弛生活并推广松弛生活的愿望究竟从何而来，这极其迷人。我也喜欢把它看作是真正像我们很久以前的祖先那样生活。他们会伴着太阳醒来。他们会感受双脚踩在大地上的感觉。他们会看着树木摇曳、看着日落，享受浆果的甘甜并细细品味。他们只会做他们生存所需的事情，然后晚上和族人安心休息。他们没有待办事项清单。他们没有
teams meetings. They didn't have Microsoft Word. They didn't have keynote presentations that needed to be done for their boss. And this soft life is about appreciating that obviously circumstances have changed. So we need jobs. We have these responsibilities. This is an element of who we are. But choosing to return to a life before productivity to find us in the time that we have. We want comfort. we want low stress. So let us jump into five ways you can really create that life for yourself at this pivotal point, how you can reprogram, re-socialize, retrain your brain to see this as the version of success you should be pursuing.
teams meetings. They didn't have Microsoft Word. They didn't have keynote presentations that needed to be done for their boss. And this soft life is about appreciating that obviously circumstances have changed. So we need jobs. We have these responsibilities. This is an element of who we are. But choosing to return to a life before productivity to find us in the time that we have. We want comfort. we want low stress. So let us jump into five ways you can really create that life for yourself at this pivotal point, how you can reprogram, re-socialize, retrain your brain to see this as the version of success you should be pursuing.|||Teams 会议。他们没有 Microsoft Word。他们没有需要为老板做的主题演讲演示。这种松弛的生活是为了认识到，显然环境已经改变了。所以我们需要工作。我们有这些责任。这是我们身份的一部分。但选择回到生产力出现之前的时代，在我们拥有的时间里寻找自我。我们需要舒适。我们需要低压力。因此，让我们来看看在这个关键时刻为你自己真正创造这种生活的五种方法，你将如何重新编程、重新社交、重新训练你的大脑，将其视为你应该追求的成功版本。
And talk about the psychology behind it. Talk about the mental impact. All of that and more after this short break. There are of course a few straightforward ways to embrace a soft life that we hear about. quite frequently, you know, prioritize self-care, especially self-care that isn't just about self-improvement, but a genuine generosity to yourself, setting boundaries with people or situations which are emotionally taxing. Another important one, practicing gratitude, incorporating rest, treating yourself every now and again, all very important, all pretty well-known
And talk about the psychology behind it. Talk about the mental impact. All of that and more after this short break. There are of course a few straightforward ways to embrace a soft life that we hear about. quite frequently, you know, prioritize self-care, especially self-care that isn't just about self-improvement, but a genuine generosity to yourself, setting boundaries with people or situations which are emotionally taxing. Another important one, practicing gratitude, incorporating rest, treating yourself every now and again, all very important, all pretty well-known|||并讨论背后的心理学。讨论精神上的影响。休息片刻后，将为您带来所有这些以及更多内容。当然，我们经常听到一些拥抱松弛生活的直接方法，你知道的，优先进行自我关怀，尤其是那种不仅关乎自我提升、而是对自己真心慷慨的自我关怀，为那些消耗情绪的人或情况设定边界。另一个重要的方法是，练习感恩，融入休息，时不时地犒劳自己，所有这些都很重要，也都广为人知。
for a good reason. But with that in mind, I really want to focus on five more specific things that are a little bit different and that you can do daily, weekly, monthly, that have an evidence base behind them. The most significant one in my mind, in my opinion, comes down to gratitude. And that is number one, go searching for joy, go searching for things to savor and embrace the kind of little things that are presented to you every day. Saver, you know, the crunchiness of the apple that you had for breakfast. Saver the fact that you found that perfect shower to. temperature, your cup of coffee, the little kid like giggling on your bus, the joy of your daily walk. You know, wake up without an alarm once a week. Choose a slower pace for your meals. Reconnect.
for a good reason. But with that in mind, I really want to focus on five more specific things that are a little bit different and that you can do daily, weekly, monthly, that have an evidence base behind them. The most significant one in my mind, in my opinion, comes down to gratitude. And that is number one, go searching for joy, go searching for things to savor and embrace the kind of little things that are presented to you every day. Saver, you know, the crunchiness of the apple that you had for breakfast. Saver the fact that you found that perfect shower to. temperature, your cup of coffee, the little kid like giggling on your bus, the joy of your daily walk. You know, wake up without an alarm once a week. Choose a slower pace for your meals. Reconnect.|||这是有原因的。但考虑到这一点，我真的很想专注于另外五件更具体的事情，它们有些不同，你可以每天、每周、每月去做，并且它们背后有证据支持。在我心中、在我看来，最重要的一点归结为感恩。那就是第一点，去寻找快乐，去寻找可以细细品味的事物，去拥抱每天呈现在你面前的那些小事。细细品味，你知道的，你早餐吃的苹果的爽脆。细细品味你找到了完美的淋浴水温、你的那杯咖啡、公交车上小孩子的咯咯笑声、你每天散步的快乐。你知道的，每周不用闹钟醒来一次。为你的饭局选择较慢的节奏。重新建立连接。
Joy as an emotion, it is so overlooked and so often confused with happiness as well, but it's a lot deeper. It's a lot more profound. Joy is elation. It's delight. It's like this whole body experience of synchronicity, almost like, you know, the best way I can explain it is the sense that in that moment you exist right now just to experience this. This is the reason you are put on this world. This is such a human experience to feel joy. This is what we're here for. Here is the thing. The more you go searching for joy, the more it tends to find you, even when you don't want it to because once our brain starts searching for a certain kind of stimulus moment thing, like a joyful thing, it becomes naturally more attuned to the presence of such things in our
Joy as an emotion, it is so overlooked and so often confused with happiness as well, but it's a lot deeper. It's a lot more profound. Joy is elation. It's delight. It's like this whole body experience of synchronicity, almost like, you know, the best way I can explain it is the sense that in that moment you exist right now just to experience this. This is the reason you are put on this world. This is such a human experience to feel joy. This is what we're here for. Here is the thing. The more you go searching for joy, the more it tends to find you, even when you don't want it to because once our brain starts searching for a certain kind of stimulus moment thing, like a joyful thing, it becomes naturally more attuned to the presence of such things in our|||快乐作为一种情感，太被忽视了，也经常与幸福混淆，但它要深得多。它要深刻得多。快乐是兴奋。是喜悦。这就像是一种全身心的同步体验，几乎就像是，你知道的，我能做出的最好解释是那种感觉：在那个时刻，你此时此刻的存在就只是为了体验这个。这就是你被带到这个世界的理由。感受到快乐是一种非常人性化的体验。这就是我们来这里的目的。事情是这样的。你越是去寻找快乐，它就越倾向于找到你，即使在你不想让它找到你的时候也是如此，因为一旦我们的大脑开始寻找某种特定的刺激、时刻或事物，比如快乐的事物，它就会自然而然地对我们身边的这类事物更加敏锐。
environment. So noticing joy makes joy more evident in your everyday. It's kind of like when you notice a yellow car and you can't stop noticing them. Like there is this green car near my house. It's like a lime green car. And now anytime I'm in a new city, a new suburb, sometimes even a new country, I see that car everywhere. I always notice it being around. Having that search for joy, that personal search for joy, is really, really helpful for your health and your life satisfaction. So there was a study published by the Royal College of Surgeons in Ireland, and it found that when we regularly experience joy day to day, something we take for granted, something we don't tend to focus on in health literature,
environment. So noticing joy makes joy more evident in your everyday. It's kind of like when you notice a yellow car and you can't stop noticing them. Like there is this green car near my house. It's like a lime green car. And now anytime I'm in a new city, a new suburb, sometimes even a new country, I see that car everywhere. I always notice it being around. Having that search for joy, that personal search for joy, is really, really helpful for your health and your life satisfaction. So there was a study published by the Royal College of Surgeons in Ireland, and it found that when we regularly experience joy day to day, something we take for granted, something we don't tend to focus on in health literature,|||环境。因此，注意到快乐会让快乐在你的日常生活中更加显现。这就好比当你注意到一辆黄色汽车时，你就无法停止注意到它们。比如我房子附近有一辆绿色的车。那是一辆青柠绿的车。现在，无论我什么时候去到一个新的城市、新的郊区，有时甚至是一个新的国家，我到处都能看到那辆车。我总是注意到它就在附近。进行这种对快乐的寻找，这种对快乐的个人寻找，对你的健康和生活满意度真的非常非常有用。因此，爱尔兰皇家外科医学院发表了一项研究，发现当我们日复一日地定期体验快乐时——这是我们认为理所当然的事情，也是我们在健康文献中往往不关注的事情——
it triggers a number of psychological but also physical changes. Better blood flow, better focus, a better mood, all things that make for a softer life. Now, that was one study, but there was another one from 2019 that was a research paper that is the perfect example of how embracing joy makes you more holistically well. So this paper measured the impact of an intervention called Picture This. I love this intervention. It's very similar to the exercise that I'm going to talk about in just a second. But in the picture of this study, the research has asked 200 of their participants in the experimental condition to use their smartphones to take at least two photographs of an event, moment, place that made them feel joyful.
it triggers a number of psychological but also physical changes. Better blood flow, better focus, a better mood, all things that make for a softer life. Now, that was one study, but there was another one from 2019 that was a research paper that is the perfect example of how embracing joy makes you more holistically well. So this paper measured the impact of an intervention called Picture This. I love this intervention. It's very similar to the exercise that I'm going to talk about in just a second. But in the picture of this study, the research has asked 200 of their participants in the experimental condition to use their smartphones to take at least two photographs of an event, moment, place that made them feel joyful.|||它会引发一系列心理和生理上的变化。更好的血液循环、更好的注意力、更好的心情，所有这些都有助于过上更松弛的生活。好吧，那是一项研究，但 2019 年还有另一项研究是一篇研究论文，它完美地展示了拥抱快乐如何让你在整体上更健康。因此，这篇论文衡量了一项名为“想象一下”（Picture This）的干预措施的影响。我喜欢这个干预。它与我马上要讲的练习非常相似。但在“想象一下”这项研究中，研究要求实验条件下的200名参与者使用智能手机拍摄至少两张能让他们感到快乐的事件、时刻或地点的照片。
and they have to do this each day for three weeks, and then they uploaded those photographs to a server for the staff to kind of look at. So the researchers gave them some examples of things to take photos off. You know, you could take a photo of the sky at sunset. You could take a photo of a good friend of getting a really good grade on a paper or a test that you worked hard for. They were also instructed. This is the second part. They're instructed to focus on the physical sensations.
and they have to do this each day for three weeks, and then they uploaded those photographs to a server for the staff to kind of look at. So the researchers gave them some examples of things to take photos off. You know, you could take a photo of the sky at sunset. You could take a photo of a good friend of getting a really good grade on a paper or a test that you worked hard for. They were also instructed. This is the second part. They're instructed to focus on the physical sensations.|||他们必须连续三周每天都这样做，然后他们将这些照片上传到服务器，供工作人员查看。因此，研究人员给他们举了一些拍照对象的例子。你知道的，你可以拍一张日落时天空的照片。你可以拍一张好朋友在一篇论文或你努力准备的测试中取得好成绩的照片。他们还被指示。这是第二部分。他们被指示关注身体感觉。
and the cognitive and emotional response that they had in that moment that they decided to take a photograph. This is actually called sensory perceptual sharpening, noticing how your senses respond to something that you're perceiving. Basically, what they were doing in this not-so-sly way was forcing their participants to take note and take notice of joy and capture a photo of the source. over that period, all these 200 people, their mood improved, they became more grateful, more motivated, they expressed that they enjoyed their life more. For some people it was actually quite a profound experience. They were like, I just didn't realize how much beauty my life had.
and the cognitive and emotional response that they had in that moment that they decided to take a photograph. This is actually called sensory perceptual sharpening, noticing how your senses responses to something that you're perceiving. Basically, what they were doing in this not-so-sly way was forcing their participants to take note and take notice of joy and capture a photo of the source. over that period, all these 200 people, their mood improved, they became more grateful, more motivated, they expressed that they enjoyed their life more. For some people it was actually quite a profound experience. They were like, I just didn't realize how much beauty my life had.|||以及他们在决定拍照那一刻产生的认知和情绪反应。这实际上被称为感觉知觉敏锐化，即注意到你的感官如何对你所感知的事物做出反应。基本上，他们以这种并不十分隐蔽的方式所做的，是迫使他们的参与者注意到并留意快乐，并拍摄一张源头的照片。在那段时间里，所有这 200 个人的情绪都有所改善，他们变得更加感激、更有动力，他们表示自己更享受生活了。对某些人来说，这实际上是一次非常深刻的体验。他们觉得，我只是没有意识到我的生活有多少美。
It really seems to show that daily experiences of awe, curiosity, gratitude, love, that can put the average person on a trajectory of gross, success. and we know that a soft life is about being present and immersed in experiencing whatever you get the privilege to enjoy and whatever you get the experience to, you know, to feel. Taking inspiration from that study and I love this study. I've talked about this on the podcast before and I've talked about it on Instagram, but I have my own version of picture this and it's called the smile file.
It really seems to show that daily experiences of awe, curiosity, gratitude, love, that can put the average person on a trajectory of gross, success. and we know that a soft life is about being present and immersed in experiencing whatever you get the privilege to enjoy and whatever you get the experience to, you know, to feel. Taking inspiration from that study and I love this study. I've talked about this on the podcast before and I've talked about it on Instagram, but I have my own version of picture this and it's called the smile file.|||这确实表明，日常生活中对敬畏、好奇心、感恩、爱的体验，可以将普通人带入一条走向巨大成功的轨道。我们知道，松弛的生活关乎活在当下，沉浸在体验你荣幸享受的一切以及你体验到的一切中，你知道的，去感受。从那项研究中获得灵感——我喜欢这项研究。我以前在播客中谈过这个，也在 Instagram 上谈过，但我有我自己的“想象一下”版本，它被称为“微笑档案”（the smile file）。
Some people also have a to-da list. These are your only instructions. Very similar to that exercise once a day. All you have to do is take a photo, screenshot, or take a note of something that has brought you joy or something that has seemed so magical to you. Almost like someone has placed this thing in your life and gone like, ta-da, look at it, enjoy it. I made this for you. Savor that moment.
Some people also have a to-da list. These are your only instructions. Very similar to that exercise once a day. All you have to do is take a photo, screenshot, or take a note of something that has brought you joy or something that has seemed so magical to you. Almost like someone has placed this thing in your life and gone like, ta-da, look at it, enjoy it. I made this for you. Savor that moment.|||有些人还有一个“哇塞清单”（to-da list）。这些就是你仅有的指令。非常类似于每天一次的那个练习。你所需要做的就是拍一张照片、截个图，或者记下一件给你带来快乐的事，或者一件对你来说似乎很神奇的事。几乎就像有人把这东西放在你的生活中，然后说：当当！看这个，好好享受吧。这是我为你做的。细细品味那一刻。
Find one moment every single day. Focus on the sensations. I think life becomes so much easier to enjoy and it's so much more gentle when you have this like outside armor of gratitude when that is the first thing that any experience that comes at you will have to penetrate an armor of gratitude. So moving on from that, our second step for adopting a soft way of living and a soft way of flourishing in our 20s, every single day I want you to remove two things from your to do list that you cannot do. Let me tell you, there is a lot we can do in a day.
Find one moment every single day. Focus on the sensations. I think life becomes so much easier to enjoy and it's so much more gentle when you have this like outside armor of gratitude when that is the first thing that any experience that comes at you will have to penetrate an armor of gratitude. So moving on from that, our second step for adopting a soft way of living and a soft way of flourishing in our 20s, every single day I want you to remove two things from your to do list that you cannot do. Let me tell you, there is a lot we can do in a day.|||每天找到一个时刻。专注于感官。我认为，当你拥有这种像感恩的外部铠甲一样的东西时，生活会变得容易享受得多，也温和得多，当这是任何迎面而来的经历都必须穿透的第一层感恩铠甲时。因此，接下来，我们采用松弛生活方式并在二十岁蓬勃发展的第二个步骤是：每天我都希望你从你的待办事项清单中移除两件你做不到的事情。让我告诉你，我们在一天之内能做的事情有很多。
There is 24 hours. That's a lot of time. But there is a lot more that we actually don't need to do. We actually never need to do. We just convince ourselves that we're lazy if we don't do it. If you grew up in an environment where you were called lazy for relaxing or you were an overachiever, every single piece of your worth was tied to what you can do in a day, your grades, how impressive. have you looked, you know, these days you may feel quite an intense internal conflict or guilt
There is 24 hours. That's a lot of time. But there is a lot more that we actually don't need to do. We actually never need to do. We just convince ourselves that we're lazy if we don't do it. If you grew up in an environment where you were called lazy for relaxing or you were an overachiever, every single piece of your worth was tied to what you can day, your grades, how impressive. have you looked, you know, these days you may feel quite an intense internal conflict or guilt|||有24个小时。那是很长的时间。但还有更多的事情其实我们根本不需要做。我们其实永远都不需要做。我们只是说服自己，如果我们不做，我们就是懒惰。如果你在一个因为放松而被说成是懒惰的环境中长大，或者你是一个追求完美的人，你价值的每一部分都与你能做的一天的工作、你的成绩、你看上去有多出色息息相关，你知道的，如今你可能会感到相当剧烈的内心冲突或内疚。
when you aren't busy. And so you feel like you have to earn your rest by creating more tasks, more challenges for yourself day in and day out. But the idea of being quote unquote lazy, it has no place in our soft error because reducing your stress by reducing how much you have to do, it's actually not laziness, it's deliberate, it's actually quite hard to do, and it is about providing yourself with space to be human rather than just being a product of how much output you can produce. Another version of that, so you can remove two things from your list today, this is a version of that that I swear by, and what I do is I have my to-do list, that is the things I really need
when you aren't busy. And so you feel like you have to earn your rest by creating more tasks, more challenges for yourself day in and day out. But the idea of being quote unquote lazy, it has no place in our soft era. Because reducing your stress by reducing how much you have to do, it's actually not laziness, it's deliberate, it's actually quite hard to do, and it is about providing yourself with space to be human rather than just being a product of how much output you can produce. Another version of that, so you can remove two things from your list today, this is a version of that that I swear by, and what I do is I have my to-do list, that is the things I really need|||当你闲下来的时候。因此，你会觉得你必须通过日复一日地为自己创造更多的任务、更多的挑战来赢得休息。但所谓“懒惰”的概念，在我们这个松弛的时代是没有立足之地的。因为通过减少你需要做的事情来减少压力，实际上并不是懒惰，这是刻意为之的，而且实际上很难做到，这是为了给自己提供一个作为人类的空间，而不是仅仅成为你能产生多少产出的产物。这是它的另一个版本，所以你今天可以从你的清单中删除两件东西，这是我深信不疑的一个版本，我做的是我有一份待办事项清单，那是我真正需要做的事情。
to do. Couldn't do them any other day. essential for my job, essential for living, essential for being a good friend, being a good partner, paying taxes, you know, those kind of things. That's my to-do list. Then I have my I would like to do list. This is the things that I would really kind of like to get done. I would really like to get around to. It's not going to be the end of the world if I don't do it. And then I have my extras list. This is the things that I would do if I have like a shit ton of time. But none of those things. are essential. Anything on my I would like to or my extras list doesn't need to be done today or tomorrow.
to do. Couldn't do them any other day. essential for my job, essential for living, essential for being a good friend, being a good partner, paying taxes, you know, those kind of things. That's my to-do list. Then I have my I would like to do list. This is the things that I would really kind of like to get done. I would really like to get around to. It's not going to be the end of the world if I don't do it. And then I have my extras list. This is the things that I would do if I have like a shit ton of time. But none of those things. are essential. Anything on my I would like to or my extras list doesn't need to be done today or tomorrow.|||无法在其他任何一天做。对我的工作至关重要，对生活至关重要，对做一个好朋友、好伴侣至关重要，交税，你知道的，诸如此类的事情。那是我的待办事项清单。然后我有我的“我想做”清单。这些是我真的很想完成的事情。我真的很想抽空去做。如果我不做，也不会是世界末日。然后我有我的“额外”清单。如果我有超级多时间的话，我会做这些事情。但这些事情都不是必需的。我“我想做”或“额外”清单上的任何事情都不需要在今天或明天完成。
Eventually they might even fall off the list altogether and nothing's going to go wrong. So you have your must list, your I would like list and your extra list. Why is this important? Well, too often, and I'm guilty of this as well, but too often we put every single small thing on our to-do list from our small tasks to our large ambitions, and it's just not helpful. I do think that we tend to do this as a way of organizing or structuring our thoughts and a way of visualizing and finding a space for remembering what needs to get done, but it has the ripple on effect of making us insanely overwhelmed because we have no vetting process. We have no vetting process as to what actually deserves to be on our daily
Eventually they might even fall off the list altogether and nothing's going to go wrong. So you have your must list, your I would like list and your extra list. Why is this important? Well, too often, and I'm guilty of this as well, but too often we put every single small thing on our to-do list from our small tasks to our large ambitions, and it's just not helpful. I do think that we tend to do this as a way of organizing or structuring our thoughts and a way of visualizing and finding a space for remembering what needs to get get done, but it has the ripple on effect of making us insanely overwhelmed because we have no vetting process. We have no vetting process as to what actually deserves to be on our daily|||最终它们甚至可能完全从清单上掉下来，也不会出任何问题。所以你有你的“必须做”清单、“我想做”清单和“额外”清单。为什么这很重要？嗯，太经常了，我也犯过这个毛病，但我们太经常把每一件小事都塞进我们的待办事项清单里，从我们的小任务到我们的宏大抱负，这根本没用。我确实认为，我们倾向于这样做是为了组织或构建我们的想法，作为一种可视化并找到空间来记住需要完成什么的方式，但它产生了连锁反应，让我们感到疯狂的压抑，因为我们没有审核流程。我们对于什么才真正值得出现在我们的日常安排中没有审核流程。
agenda. It's like everything from do the dishes to find my birth certificate, to get a new job to like insert huge task here. Because of this, we never actually finished the to-do list. Every day a new task is kind of carried over. You've added on more items, which you can't do anyways. Then you don't do them. You feel like a failure. Even when you already did all the things that you already needed to do. So why is it important to have a realistic list rather than an ambitious list? It's because of how our brains prioritize and think about unfinished tasks. They become rather intrusive. There is a natural spotlight on everything that we haven't done rather than on what we have done.
agenda. It's like everything from do the dishes to find my birth certificate, to get a new job to like insert huge task here. Because of this, we never actually finished the to-do list. Every day a new task is kind of carried over. You've added on more items, which you can't do anyways. Then you don't do them. You feel like a failure. Even when you already did all the things that you already needed to do. So why is it important to have a realistic list rather than an ambitious list? It's because of how our brains prioritize and think about unfinished tasks. They become rather intrusive. There is a natural spotlight on everything that we haven't done rather than on what we have done.|||这就像从洗碗到找出生证明，到找一份新工作，再到在此处插入巨大的任务。正因为如此，我们从未真正完成过待办事项清单。每天都会结转一项新任务。你增加了更多的项目，反正你也做不到。然后你没有做。你觉得自己是个失败者。即使你已经做完了你需要做所有事情。那么，为什么拥有一张切合实际的清单而不是雄心勃勃的清单很重要呢？这是因为我们的大脑如何优先处理和思考未完成的任务。它们变得相当具有侵入性。自然有一道聚光灯照在我们还没有做的事情上，而不是我们已经做过的事情上。
So this is due to a psychological phenomenon known as the zygonic effect, which basically says that we tend to fixate on interrupted tasks or incomplete tasks more than others. When we feel like we have, I hate using this word, but failed to do something, something that we needed to do. This creates this underlying cognitive tension, and it means that our brain keeps coming back to it, keep saying, hey, we haven't finished that yet, we haven't finished that yet. Even as you're trying to switch off, even as you're trying to fall asleep, even when you are totally exhausted, even when actually there's no need to do that thing today.
So this is due to a psychological phenomenon known as the zygonic effect, which basically says that we tend to fixate on interrupted tasks or incomplete tasks more than others. When we feel like we have, I hate using this word, but failed to do something, something that we needed to do. This creates this underlying cognitive tension, and it means that our brain keeps coming back to it, keep saying, hey, we haven't finished that yet, we haven't finished that yet. Even as you're trying to switch off, even as you're trying to fall asleep, even when you are totally exhausted, even when actually there's no need to do that thing today.|||所以这是由于一种被称为蔡格尼克效应（zygonic effect）的心理现象，它基本说明了我们往往比其他事情更执着于被中断的任务或未完成的任务。当我们觉得自己——我讨厌用这个词——但未能做成某事时，那是我们需要做的事情。这会产生潜在的认知紧张，这意味着我们的大脑会不断回到它身边，不断地说：嘿，我们还没完成那个呢，我们还没完成那个呢。甚至当你试图关机时，甚至当你试图入睡时，甚至当你筋疲力尽时，甚至当实际上今天没有必要做那件事时。
In some ways, this is sometimes helpful, you know, when you're really under the pump, you don't want to forget things, you don't want things to slip off the list, but you are not meant to feel. that way all the time because then everything becomes about what you didn't do with your time rather than prioritizing what you chose to do with your time in order to be more present in your life. So this is my new rule for myself. Yes, I have my must like and like my extras list. But I also say if any sentence starts with I could, such as I could do this, I could add more things to my to-do list. I could sign up for new projects. I could, you know, add this extra element
In some ways, this is sometimes helpful, you know, when you're really under the pump, you don't want to forget things, you don't want things to slip off the list, but you are not meant to feel. that way all the time because then everything becomes about what you didn't do with your time rather than prioritizing what you chose to do with your time in order to be more present in your life. So this is my new rule for myself. Yes, I have my must like and like my extras list. But I also say if any sentence starts with I could, such as I could do this, I could add more things to my to-do list. I could sign up for new projects. I could, you know, add this extra element|||在某些方面，这有时是有帮助的，你知道的，当你压力极大的时候，你不想忘记事情，你不想让事情从清单上漏掉，但你不应该一直都有那种感觉。因为那样的话，一切都成了关于你用你的时间没有做什么，而不是优先考虑你选择用你的时间做什么，以便更好地活在你的生活中。所以这是我给自己定的新规则。是的，我有我的“必须”清单和“额外”清单。但我也会说，如果任何句子以“我可以”开头，比如“我可以做这个”、“我可以给我的待办事项清单添加更多东西”、“我可以报名参加新项目”、“我可以，你知道的，添加这个额外的元素”，
that's going to take a lot of time. I could find time in my day. I have to shut it down. Any sentence at this time in my life when everything is so busy that starts with I could is I can't. I only have space for things that are urgent, for things that are important, for things that I want to do. Because I was doing all this stuff before that just really drained me enormously and it actually didn't even matter. Like it had no impact on my life. It wouldn't have made my life better. It wasn't really doing anything. It wasn't important. It wouldn't have mattered whether it was done or not. And it made my life heavy. And, and, you know, it was things I didn't even care about. And the things that I did care about, I wasn't able to prioritize because I was carrying the stress of these tasks that were
that's going to take a lot of time. I could find time in my day. I have to shut it down. Any sentence at this time in my life when everything is so busy that starts with I could is I can-t. I only have space for things that are urgent, for things that are important, for things that I want to do. Because I was doing all this stuff before that just really drained me enormously and it actually didn't even matter. Like it had no impact on my life. It wouldn't have made my life better. It really wasn't doing anything. It wasn't important. It wouldn't have mattered whether it was done or not. And it made my life heavy. And, and, you know, it was things I didn't even care about. And the things that I did care about, I wasn't able to prioritize because I was carrying the stress of these tasks that were|||这会花很多时间。我可以在我的一天中腾出时间。我必须把它掐断。在我人生的这个时期，当所有事情都如此繁忙时，任何以“我可以”开头的句子，我都得改成“我不行”。我只为紧急的事情、重要的事情、我想做的事情留出空间。因为我以前做的所有这些事情真的极大地耗尽了我的精力，而实际上它们根本不重要。就像它对我的生活没有任何影响一样。它不会让我的生活变得更好。它真的什么也没做。这并不重要。做不做都无所谓。它让我的生活变得沉重。而且，而且，你知道的，这些甚至是我根本不关心的东西。而我真正关心的东西，我却无法优先处理，因为我背负着这些任务的压力，这些任务是
unnecessary. You know, someone said to me recently, I think this really does summarize it. If you don't have to struggle, don't. Don't force yourself to struggle just because you think it means you deserve more, just because you think that people are going to think you're lazy if you don't. So tip number two, cut down that to do list, please and thank you. We're going to take a short break, but when we return, I want to discuss my remaining three steps or pieces of advice for creating that soft, tender, gentle life that you deserve. in your 20s. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world.
unnecessary. You know, someone said to me recently, I think this really does summarize it. If you don't have to struggle, don't. Don't force yourself to struggle just because you think it means you deserve more, just because you think that people are going to think you're lazy if you don't. So tip number two, cut down that to do list, please and thank you. We're going to take a short break, but when we return, I want to discuss my remaining three steps or pieces of advice for creating that soft, tender, gentle life that you deserve. in your 20s. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world.|||不必要的。你知道，最近有人对我说，我认为这真的总结得很到位：如果你不必挣扎，就别挣扎。不要强迫自己去挣扎，仅仅因为你认为这意味着你配得上更多，仅仅因为你认为如果你不这样做，人们会认为你懒惰。所以第二条建议：精简待办事项清单，求求你们了，谢谢。我们将进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我想讨论我剩下的三个步骤或建议，以帮助你在二十岁时创造那种你应得的、柔和的、体贴的、温柔的生活。请继续收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that, dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that, dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.|||我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.|||也就是 I-Heart Radio 应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何平台上的 T-W-O-Persent。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at it）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know I mean at this point this is the second episode where we've discussed crack
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know I mean at this point this is the second episode where we've discussed crack|||每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我愿意随时谈论可卡因，但只是为了让你们知道，我的意思是，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集
so I'm starting to see that there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now So Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years
so I'm starting to see that there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now So Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years|||所以我开始看到其中有一条主线我们现在也将艾滋病摆上台面所以谢谢你把那句话说完我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了吗真的吗是的对我来说这是最重要的年份之一
For black people in American history Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
For black people in American history Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field|||在美洲历史上对黑人而言收听《回顾过去》在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何平台上欢迎来到我的新播客《以硬核方式学习》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师，凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,|||以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给你们。我说的是，特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这件东西。而我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候做得够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的事情。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,|||因为你发现在世上做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，我们一起进行关于疗愈的真实对话，
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct?
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct?|||成长、父职、压力和目标的探讨，尽在我的新播客《以硬核方式学习》。打开你免费的 I-Heart radio 应用。搜索《以硬核方式学习》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己身处亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她口供中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了长达数年的法庭诉讼，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了某个人的这个特定测试，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.|||我篡改过测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your|||我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《爱之陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在 Iheart radio 应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《爱之陷阱》播客。
podcasts. One of the other crucial elements of creating a routine and a lifestyle that lets you go slowly and at your own pace is developing a better relationship with stress. Now, that probably sounds unrealistic, undoable for many of us. Stress is, of course, it's a necessary part of life, you know, like it or not. you are never going to eliminate it entirely, nor actually should you want to, because you'd miss out on so much important information. But we can get better at regulating our nervous system so that it's not being triggered by unnecessary stresses, things that are minor stresses, things that really don't deserve that much attention and energy.
podcasts. One of the other crucial elements of creating a routine and a lifestyle that lets you go slowly and at your own pace is developing a better relationship with stress. Now, that probably sounds unrealistic, undoable for many of us. Stress is, of course, it's a necessary part of life, you know, like it or not. you are never going to eliminate it entirely, nor actually should you want to, because you'd miss out on so much important information. But we can get better at regulating our nervous system so that it's not being triggered by unnecessary stresses, things that are minor stresses, things that really don't deserve that much attention and energy.|||建立一种能让你放慢脚步、按自己的节奏生活的日常规律和生活方式的另一个关键要素，是与压力建立更好的关系。现在，对我们许多人来说，这听起来可能很不现实，无法做到。压力当然是生活中不可或缺的一部分，你知道的，不管你喜欢与否。你永远无法完全消除它，实际上你也不应该想去消除它，因为你会错过很多重要的信息。但我们可以更好地调节我们的神经系统，使其不会被不必要的压力所触发，那些微不足道的压力，那些真正不值得花那么多注意力和精力的东西。
You know, the daily hassles. Stress has an impact. We want to be selective with when it is. activated because when our fight or flight response is consistently set off, it changes our immune system response. It suppresses digestion. It reduces our body's ability to heal itself. There are so many cognitive impacts. It actually does put your body under a lot of tension. It's like a vigorous workout for your body. And, you know, workouts are great. Workouts keep you healthy. You don't want to be doing like four or five of them a day. It's going to put a strain.
You know, the daily hassles. Stress has an impact. We want to be selective with when it is. activated because when our fight or flight response is consistently set off, it changes our immune system response. It suppresses digestion. It reduces our body's ability to heal itself. There are so many cognitive impacts. It actually does put your body under a lot of tension. It's like a vigorous workout for your body. And, you know, workouts are great. Workouts keep you healthy. You don't want to be doing like four or five of them a day. It's going to put a strain.|||你知道的，日常的麻烦。压力会产生影响。我们希望对它激活的时间有所选择，因为当我们的战斗或逃跑反应持续被触发时，它会改变我们的免疫系统反应。它会抑制消化。它会降低身体自我修复的能力。有太多的认知影响了。它确实让你的身体承受了很大的紧张。这就像给你的身体进行了一次剧烈的锻炼。而且，你知道的，锻炼很好。锻炼能让你保持健康。你可不想一天做四五次。这会带来负担。
It also just like doesn't feel nice. That's like a pretty simple way to say it. I've noticed though that so few of us realize how often we are actually being pushed into that stressed state, how often our environment is triggering a response that was meant for survival. But this is not a matter of survival. You know, a workplace deadline, missing a train, having an argument with a friend is not a matter of survival. But we cannot help but feel like this insane stress. response and this fight or flight response is being triggered because we have been trained by our environment to be more an edge. So this is a long way of saying number three, if you want a soft life,
It also just like doesn't feel nice. That's like a pretty simple way to say it. I've noticed though that so few of us realize how often we are actually being pushed into that stressed state, how often our environment is triggering a response that was meant for survival. But this is not a matter of survival. You know, a workplace deadline, missing a train, having an argument with a friend is not a matter of survival. But we cannot help but feel like this insane stress. response and this fight or flight response is being triggered because we have been trained by our environment to be more an edge. So this is a long way of saying number three, if you want a soft life,|||而且感觉也不太好。这算是一种相当简单的说法。不过我注意到，我们当中很少有人意识到我们究竟有多么频繁地被推入那种压力状态，我们的环境究竟有多么频繁地触发本意是为了生存的反应。但这并非生死攸关的问题。你知道的，工作截止日期、错过火车、与朋友争吵都不是生死攸关的事。但我们不禁感到这种疯狂的压力反应和战斗或逃跑反应被触发了，因为我们已经接受了环境的训练，变得更加神经质。所以说了这么多，第三点是，如果你想要一种松弛的生活，
we have to improve how we regulate our nervous system in organic ways, in ways that we are evolutionarily and our ancestors would have regulated their emotional response and their stress response. A regulated nervous system like that turn, it has been getting a lot of buzz online recently. I've noticed this. What it basically means is that your body and your mind can effectively respond to stress. So it is not the complete removal, the complete absence of stress. It's actually important to note that it is about having this important two-way street relationship with stress where stress is welcomed, but it is not allowed to dominate.
we have to improve how we regulate our nervous system in organic ways, in ways that we are evolutionarily and our ancestors would have regulated their emotional response and their stress response. A regulated nervous system like that turn, it has been getting a lot of buzz online recently. I've noticed this. What it basically means is that your body and your mind can effectively respond to stress. So it is not the complete removal, the complete absence of stress. It's actually important to note that it is about having this important two-way street relationship with stress where stress is welcomed, but it is not allowed to dominate.|||我们必须以有机的方式、以我们在进化过程中以及我们的祖先调节其情绪反应和压力反应的方式来改善我们调节神经系统的方式。像这样转变的“受到调节的神经系统”，最近在网上引起了很大的轰动。我注意到了这一点。它的基本意思是，你的身体和心灵可以有效地对压力做出反应。因此，它并不是完全消除压力，完全没有压力。实际上重要的是要注意，它是与压力建立这种重要的双向街关系，其中压力受到欢迎，但不允许它主导一切。
You are able to return to a balanced calm state after it is past. And that state, that balance is called homeostasis. It's crucial because it means that your nervous system isn't overreactive, it's not stuck, it allows you to be flexible, it allows you to adapt to various situations, you are not a tense creature. Here are some ways that we can get to that regulated state. You need to have a process for grounding yourself
You are able to return to a balanced calm state after it is past. And that state, that balance is called homeostasis. It's crucial because it means that your nervous system isn't overreactive, it's not stuck, it allows you to be flexible, it allows you to adapt to various situations, you are not a tense creature. Here are some ways that we can get to that regulated state. You need to have a process for grounding yourself|||在压力过去后，你能够恢复到平衡平静的状态。那种状态，那种平衡被称为稳态。这至关重要，因为它意味着你的神经系统不会过度反应，不会陷入僵局，它允许你保持灵活性，允许你适应各种情况，你不再是一个紧张的生物。以下是一些我们可以达到这种调节状态的方法。你需要有一个让自己脚踏实地的过程
and for remaining present when everything in you is calling to panic. I always repeat to myself, just be where your feet are. Just be where your feet are. And that means taking off my socks. I don't know if that's gross for some people, but whatever. Take off my socks. I take off my shoes. I just place my feet on the floor and I say,
而且要在内心中所有声音都叫嚣着恐慌时保持现状。我总是对自己重复，就呆在你双脚所在的地方。就呆在你双脚所在的地方。这意味着脱掉我的袜子。我不知道这对某些人来说是不是有点恶心，但无所谓。脱掉我的袜子。我脱掉鞋子。我只是把双脚放在地板上，然后我说，
the only thing that I'm going to concern myself with is whatever is 10 centimeters from where I'm standing. This is my zone, this is my present, this is what I can control. Not the future, not others, not the past. I'm going to take a moment in the stress state to be where my feet are. This is even better when you combine it with like a natural environmental setting. So this kind of grounding, it's called earthing, when we combine that centering technique with nature. earthing really focuses on realigning your electrical, your neural energy with the earth. You know, those words, they might not sound scientific, but the research behind this type of grounding,
我唯一需要关心的就是距离我站立的地方10厘米以内的东西。这是我的地盘，这是我的现在，这是我能控制的。不是未来，不是别人，也不是过去。我要在压力状态下花点时间呆在我双脚所在的地方。如果把它与自然环境结合起来，效果会更好。因此，这种接地气的方法被称为“接地疗法”（earthing），也就是我们将这种定心技巧与自然结合起来。接地疗法真正专注于将你的电信号、你的神经能量与地球重新对齐。你知道，这些词听起来可能不够科学，但这种接地方法背后的研究，
it really is the best study that I've come across this ever. It talks about how our lost connection with nature and the earth has basically caused our nervous system to, no longer have a stable environment in which to calm itself. You know, we no longer sleep on the ground. We rarely walk barefoot outdoors. We live and we work inside. We spend so much of our time disconnected, like up far above the ground in high rises, not out in nature.
这绝对是我见过的最好的研究。它谈到了我们与自然和地球失去联系如何从根本上导致我们的神经系统不再拥有一个稳定的环境来让自己平静下来。你知道，我们不再睡在地面上。我们很少在户外赤脚走路。我们在室内生活和工作。我们花大量的时间处于失联状态，比如在高层建筑中远离地面，而不是置身于大自然中。
You know, some of us wouldn't spend more than an hour outside a day. Everything is loud, busy, or vestimulating, urgent. That never ends. And all that external information means we, need to be constantly on so our threshold for stress has been lowered. But when we practice earthing, we return our body and our mind to the place it evolved from, to where it belongs, to where it can recalibrate itself and feel calm. And a grounded body is a healthier and stable body. The most fascinating part of this study, though, and you can't have to see it to believe it.
你知道，我们中的一些人每天在户外呆的时间不会超过一个小时。一切都是喧嚣的、忙碌的、过度刺激的、紧急的。而且永无止境。所有这些外部信息意味着我们，需要保持时刻在线，因此我们的压力阈值降低了。但是当我们练习接地时，我们让身心回归到它进化而来的地方，回归到它属于的地方，回归到它能够自我校准并感到平静的地方。一个身心稳定的身体才是更健康、更稳定的身体。然而，这项研究中最迷人的部分是，你必须亲自看到它才会相信。
Because I read this and I was like, I need some more evidence of this. I need something. I need a graph, I need a picture, they had them. Basically, in the study, they looked at thermal imaging of a person's body before and after-earthing. So thermal imaging basically looks at body temperature. And lower body temperature would typically mean less inflammation, perhaps even less pain. That was very clearly documented in these images. People were talking about how even spending 30 months.
因为我读到这个的时候我想，我需要这方面的更多证据。我需要点什么。我需要一张图表，我需要一张图片，他们确实有。基本上，在这项研究中，他们观察了人体在接地前后的热成像。所以热成像基本上就是看体温。较低的体温通常意味着较少的炎症，甚至可能意味着较少的疼痛。这些图像中非常清楚地记录了这一点。人们谈论到甚至只花30个月。
minutes, earthing themselves. So just basically grounding, using nature. They felt more calm, their pain from certain chronic health problems or certain joint pains, things like that, was relieved. They felt less stressed, less like almost even hot, less jittery. All of these coming down to nature's innate capacity, it's innate role as our friend and as our collaborator in handling our motions. So there's some other things that you can do to help with that regulation. Cold showers in the morning,
分钟的接地时间。也就是基本上通过亲近自然来接地。他们感到更加平静，他们因某些慢性健康问题或某些关节痛等引起的疼痛得到了缓解。他们感到压力减轻了，几乎甚至不觉得燥热，不那么神经质了。所有这些都归结为大自然固有的能力，它作为我们处理情绪的朋友和合作者的固有角色。所以你还可以做一些其他事情来帮助调节。早晨洗冷水澡，
that's a big one at the moment. Personally, don't like it. No, it works. Not for me, but just to put it on the table. You can also do progressive muscle relaxation, which is beautiful. You can get guided versions of this online, which I really recommend.
这目前是一个很大的趋势。就个人而言，我不喜欢。不，这很有用。对我来说不适合，但只是把它提出来。你还可以做渐进式肌肉放松，这非常棒。你可以在网上找到这方面的引导版本，我真的很推荐。
This one was something that I thought of or I was like, huh, this would really work. And I tried it the other day and it was actually very, very interesting, unplugging from your phone or your headphones when you go for a walk. So we often, you know, you and me both, we are listening to podcasts, we are listening to music. We are calling our friends. We've got our noise cancelling headphones on. We got earbuds in. Instead, next time you go for a walk, take your headphones off, just pay attention to your environment. And it means that we
这一点是我自己想到的，或者当时觉得，嗯，这真的会管用。前几天我尝试了一下，实际上非常非常有趣，那就是在你去散步时，拔掉手机或耳机的插头。所以我们经常，你知道，你我都一样，我们在听播客，我们在听音乐。我们在给朋友打电话。我们戴着降噪耳机。我们塞着耳塞。相反，下次你去散步时，摘下耳机，只需关注你的周围环境。这意味着我们
don't experience this disconnection between what we're listening to, like our senses and what we're seeing. So our eyes and our ears are not processing different information. I just think that all those options are free. Like you can literally do them tomorrow. But it really just like reconnects your mind and your body to your environment in a way that our current situation and our current work, life, travel, existence doesn't really promote. This really brings me to my next big tip. Look at this amazing segue I'm about to perform because my next piece of advice is really, really related to that. And it's related to how we treat self-care as a consumerist act when we should be focusing more on creation. Self-care is really, really important, but it's so often associated with spending money and having more, more skin care, more candles, more luxuries, buying yourself little things.
不会体验到我们正在听的声音、我们的感官与我们所看到的东西之间的这种脱节。所以我们的眼睛和耳朵没有在处理不同的信息。我只是觉得所有这些选项都是免费的。就像你明天就可以直接去做一样。但它确实让你的思维和身体重新与环境连接起来，这是我们目前的生活方式、工作、旅行和生存状态所不太提倡的。这真的让我谈到了我的下一个重大建议。看看我即将进行的这段精彩的过渡，因为我的下一个建议与此真正、真正相关。它与我们如何将自我关怀视为一种消费主义行为有关，而我们本应更多地关注创造。自我关怀真的非常重要，但它经常与花钱和拥有更多东西联系在一起——更多的护肤品、更多的蜡烛、更多的奢侈品、给自己买小物件。
This is all really, really nice, right? I do it all the time. a joy getting a new little trinket. It's a joy getting something that you've really worked hard for. But it can also make self-care unattainable. And after a while, I would make the argument that it makes self-care quite shallow if you can just like buy yourself a better mood. It's of course going to give you the dopamine hit that you want because it is an act of consumerism. And companies are great at leveraging that to get you to think that self-care really just means buying more things. really just means consuming more things, thinking it's going to make you happier.
这真的很美好，对吧？我一直都在这么做。得到一个小饰品是一种快乐。得到一件你真正通过努力换来的东西是一种快乐。但它也可能让自我关怀变得遥不可及。过了一段时间，我会认为，如果你只是给自己买一个好心情，这会让自我关怀变得相当肤浅。它当然会给你想要的内啡肽刺激，因为它是一种消费主义行为。而各大公司非常善于利用这一点，让你认为自我关怀真的只是意味着买更多东西。真的只是意味着消耗更多东西，以为这会让你更快乐。
There was a really great Vox article written about this in, I think, June or July this year. It's called How the Self Care Industry made us so lonely. And it talks about how self-care used to be a term that meant nurturing yourself by filling your cup with community and creation and rest, expression. All of these are so psychologically nourishing. But nowadays, those things are harder to come by and they're harder to prioritize because we are. So disconnected, those spaces aren't as available, those communities aren't as available. And so we replace them with what we can buy or what is most convenient and available, which can actually make our lives quite heavy. We talked about this in
今年6月或7月左右，Vox上发表了一篇关于这的很棒的文章。它叫做《自我关怀产业是如何让我们如此孤独的》。它谈到自我关怀曾经是一个术语，意味着通过用社群、创造力和休息、表达来滋养自己，让你的心灵充满力量。所有这些在心理上都极具滋养作用。但如今，这些东西更难得到了，也更难排在优先位置，因为我们。如此脱节，那些空间不再那么容易获得，那些社群不再那么容易获得。所以我们用我们能买到的东西或最方便、最容易获得的东西来取代它们，这实际上会让我们的生活变得相当沉重。我们在
last week's episodes. If you're up to date, last week we talked about hobbies. I don't know if it was last week or on Tuesday now. Our most recent episode we talked about hobbies. And I talked about how we are so exhausted from how busy society keeps us that often we just want to do what's easiest. We want to have the quickest meal. We want the most convenient way to switch off our brain by scrolling, by watching TV, all of which have their place. But continuously, choosing that as your place to relax, choosing that as your source of kind of decompressing, it's going to detract from your life. It's going to make it a lot less tasty. If you want that delicate, soft, cozy life, you need to make more space for creating things
上周的节目中谈到了这一点。如果你消息灵通的话，我们上周谈到了爱好。我不知道是上周还是周二。我们最近的一期节目谈到了爱好。我谈到了我们对社会让我们变得如此忙碌感到如此筋疲力尽，以至于通常我们只想做最容易的事。我们想要最快的饭菜。我们想要最方便的方式来通过刷手机、看电视来关闭大脑，所有这些都有它们的价值。但如果一直把这作为你放松的地方，把这作为你减压的来源，它会损害你的生活。它会让生活变得乏味得多。如果你想要那种精致、柔软、舒适的生活，你需要为创造事物腾出更多空间
and more space for expression and dedicate less time, less money, less room to just consuming. So two to three days a week, I want you to do a week. I want you to invest in creation as a way to feel more connected to what you're doing. So your food, your items, your space, your hobbies, take the extra 30 minutes, the extra hour to really pour some care and love into your dinner or your breakfast and to feel proud of what you're making yourself, how you're nourishing yourself. Take an afternoon off. Take an afternoon off on your weekend to pursue a creative project, get a herb garden,
并为表达腾出更多空间，减少用于单纯消费的时间、金钱和空间。所以每周两到三天，我希望你能做到。我希望你把创造力作为一种投资，以此来感到与你正在做的事情更加紧密地联系在一起。所以你的食物、你的物品、你的空间、你的爱好，多花额外的30分钟、额外的一个小时，真正倾注一些关怀和爱到你的晚餐或早餐中，为自己制作的东西感到自豪，为自己如何滋养自己感到自豪。腾出一个下午。在你的周末腾出一个下午去追求一个创意项目，弄一个香草园，
volunteer, take care of someone else, be generous to someone else, put something back into the world. That is a real true act of softness, being open enough to want to give and not just receive. Finally, rethink what you believe success should look like. This is a big aspect of shifting from a productive, heavy life to a slower, softer, gentler life. Typically, And historically, our biggest indicators of success, they are material and they are social. You make more money, you receive more praise, you have more respect, you have a nicer house. But what does any of that actually mean if you are always in a rush anyways? And if you never have this space to enjoy it?
去做义工，照顾别人，对别人慷慨大度，为世界做点贡献。那才是真正温柔的行为，内心足够开放，想要付出而不仅仅是接受。最后，重新思考你对成功的定义。这是从高效但沉重的生活转变为更慢、更柔软、更温和的生活的一个重要方面。通常情况下，从历史上看，我们最大的成功指标是物质和社会的。你赚更多的钱，你获得更多的赞誉，你赢得更多的尊重，你住更好的房子。但如果你无论如何总是行色匆匆，这一切到底意味着什么？如果你从来没有空间去享受它？
What makes that a more desirable life than the soft life? You know, because quite frankly, you can have all those things and a lot of people have experienced all of those things and still said, I am quite miserable. So let's consider the alternative. A balanced lifestyle. A day filled of variety. Time to just exist. Enjoy your experiences.
是什么让这样的生活比柔软的生活更令人向往？你知道，因为坦白说，你可以拥所有这些东西，很多人体验过所有这些东西，却依然说，我非常痛苦。所以让我们考虑一下替代方案。一种平衡的生活方式。充满变化的一天。有时间去单纯地存在。享受你的经历。
Time to socialize to build connection. Room to slow down. Maturing, to me at least, is realizing that is very appealing. That is the outcome we should want. A few weeks ago, I did an episode. I think it's called How to Be Truly Successful in Your 20s, Episode 221. Episode 221, yes. And I really wanted to wreck you to listen to that because when we talk about redefining success,
有时间社交来建立联系。有慢下来的空间。对我而言，成熟至少是意识到那是极具吸引力的。那是我们应该追求的结果。几周前，我做了一期节目。我想它叫做《如何在20多岁时真正获得成功》，第221期。第221期，是的。我真的很想强烈推荐你去听听那期节目，因为当我们谈论重新定义成功时，
that's like the best place to turn. It goes so in depth. And it could be a wake-up call that you might need to hear that we're putting so much weight on the traditional notions of success, no fault of our own. That's how we've been socialized, it's how we've been conditioned, how we've been raised. But at their center, they are about self-sacrifice, they're about discipline, productivity, image. The alternative is about giving, enjoying, resting, slowing down, caring.
那是最好的去处。它讲得非常深入。这可能是一记警钟，是你可能需要听到的，即我们把太多的分量压在了传统的成功观念上，这并不是我们的错。这是我们被社会化的方式，是我们被规训的方式，是我们被抚养长大方式。但它们的核心是关于自我牺牲、纪律、生产力、形象。而替代方案则是关于给予、享受、休息、放慢脚步、关怀。
And, you know, I just think that's more valuable. It doesn't mean you can't still be successful in traditional ways. but it's about kind of opting out of the rap race at some point and being like, huh, this, I can't win in the system. I can't win if I have to just keep being productive for the rest of my life to obtain all these sweet, beautiful joys that they're telling me I'm obtaining because of this work, but never actually being able to enjoy them. Like you kind of start to really see how that's not a healthy cycle.
而且，你知道，我只是觉得那更有价值。这并不意味着你不能以传统的方式获得成功。但它更多的是关于在某个时刻选择退出老鼠赛跑，然后心想，嗯，在这个系统中我无法赢。如果我必须为了余生不断保持高效来获得他们告诉我由于这项工作而正在获得的这些甜蜜、美丽的快乐，却永远无法真正享受它们，那我绝不可能赢。你会开始真正明白这为什么不是一个健康的循环。
So choose the gentle life. It's the simple things. It's the minimalistic things, not the flashy things. It's joy, nature, community, creation, a regulated nervous system. That is true wealth to me. And the tips that we've shared today will hopefully bring you closer to having more of that in your life. So in wrapping up this episode, I'm hoping that this left an impression on you or it just made you think that's really what's important. I hope you please do just one of these things.
所以选择温和的生活。这是关于简单的事情。这是极简主义的事情，而不是浮华的事情。这是快乐、自然、社群、创造、一个受到调节的神经系统。对我来说，那才是真正的财富。我们今天分享的建议有望让你更接近在生活中拥有更多这样的体验。所以在结束本期节目时，我希望这能给你留下深刻印象，或者只是让你觉得这才是真正重要的。我希望你能至少尝试做其中一件事。
Just see if it helps. You could even literally just not set an alarm every now and again, slow down, cook a nice meal, see what happens, see if life feels more fulfilling and more rich. If you have listened this far, thank you so much. Just a reminder that if you want to pre-order my book, you can do that right now at this very minute that you are listening. If you just want to check out the cover, if you just want to see what the blurb looks like, I don't know, whenever floats your boat, I'll leave a link in the description. It truly is an honor to get to announce this. to you guys, my wonderful listeners today. As for this episode, as for the podcast, make sure you have left us a five-star review. Make sure you are following along on Apple or Spotify. So you get
看看它是否有帮助。你甚至可以每隔一段时间就不设闹钟，慢下来，做一顿美餐，看看会发生什么，看看生活是否感觉更加充实和丰富。如果你一直听到了这里，非常感谢。顺便提醒一下，如果你想预订我的书，你可以在你正在收听的此时此刻进行预订。如果你只是想看看封面，如果你只是想看看简介长什么样，不管怎样，随你喜欢，我会在描述中留下链接。今天向你们——我听众中的美妙大伙儿——宣布这件事，我深感荣幸。至于本期节目，至于这个播客，请确保给我们留下了五星好评。请确保在Apple或Spotify上关注我们。这样你就能
alerted when your episodes come out. It's almost December, which you know means the 12 days of guests. I can't wait to announce who is coming on. You can follow us on Instagram if you want a sneak peek of that as well at That Psychology Podcast. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself embrace the soft life and we will talk very very soon. Hey, what's good y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that
在节目发布时收到提醒。马上就要到12月了，你知道这意味着12天的嘉宾环节。我等不及要宣布谁要来了。如果你也想抢先看一眼，可以在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology Podcast。直到下次，注意安全。保持善良。对自己温柔一点，拥抱柔软的生活，我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好！你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《The Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人的经历，进行那些在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，
you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下双胞胎，但这似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，甚至更多。我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的大脑都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个
strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是TWA%。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱的。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的好闺蜜。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。